hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt und herzlich willkommen zu unserem
jahresrückblick 2009 10 zum ersten mal
dieses jahres normalerweise machen sie
ja bei rtl jahresrückblick im august ja
damit die lebkuchen saison eröffnet wird
aber wir haben gedacht kommen wir müssen
natürlich warten bis der 31 dezember ist
und dann einen jahresrückblick machen
in diesem video geben wir einen kleinen
jahresrückblick was alles so passiert
die highlights des jahres 2019 und
erklären diverse fragen von euch fragen
wie wer hat die größeren flüsse
das war eine frage von zuschauern
städten habe mein gott wo dieser viele
schießen die uns auf dem kanal wohl kaum
wir starten im jahresrückblick
ich würde sagen wir starten vielleicht
mit den highlights von euch die
meistgeklickten videos des jahres 2009
10 kommt diese überraschung ich muss
betonen ich bin ja ursprünglich ein koch
und back kanal also bei mir geht's
rezepte haushaltstipps und die
meistgeklickten videos 2009 10 waren die
tropfen die top 10 halten wir fest krass
was haben wir acht kinderzimmer
einrichten
das kinderzimmer einrichten unsere
eltern ruhm tour außenfassade auch im
fassade wenn ihr heute außenfassade bei
youtube ein geben wir auf unser video
ich habe also zum ersten mal in meinem
leben eine außen verein haus
eingekleideten ein haus verkleidet eine
außenfassade gemacht und euch hat das
mega interessiert da frage ich mich so
langsam erlischt und kuchenbar kanada
solcher fachhandwerker an werken
handwerker oder segert serben machen
diese dinge die uns spaß macht
ja und die scheint auch zu intercell und
die besten videos die top fünf videos
waren alles einrichtungs videos und
handeln bietet finde ich cool ich würde
gerne istanbul weil das inhalt wirklich
dinge die mich gerade beschäftigt haben
oder uns und ich habe mir gedacht okay
wie mache ich jetzt das kinderzimmer wie
gestalte ich freue mich das kinderzimmer
ein so dass ella einfach ihr zimmer
immer ordentlich hält und anscheinend
sind es auch fragen und themen die euch
bewegen und deswegen freut mich umso
mehr dass wir bei euch gut ankommen
aber dennoch bleibe ich natürlich
einkochen bad kanal aber ich werde
weiterhin immer wieder auch die themen
nämlich beschäftigt die uns beschäftigen
ich glaube es findet ihr auch ganz cool
ja und das immer selber immer gespannt
was neues auf uns zukommt was auch ein
highlight war finde ich muss ich sagen
kit wurde dieses irre letztes jahr 100
jahre alt und zu diesem anlass habe ich
eine 3d kitchenaid torte gebacken
am anfang habe ich mich ein bisschen
gewundert dass kein irgendwie reagiert
und dann kam ich drauf die menschen die
haben nicht verstanden dass ich eine
kitchenette gebacken habe eine maschine
gedacht nächsten view - amy chua dabei
war sie gebacken
also was zum 100 jährigen jubiläum von
kitchenaid in frankfurt auf der ambiente
und das die ganze halle ist gekommen und
das hat mittel feiert und das haben auch
viele freunde dort den rudolf von er
wieder in jörg von kaymer da genau und
richtig coole geschichte war eine coole
kitchenette geburtstagsparty ja was auch
ein absolutes highlight war war meine
new york reise das war für das erste mal
new york für mich und ich war da mit
galileo wir haben diese oder letztes
jahr merkel folgen schon gerne gemacht
aber new york war wirklich ein richtiges
morgen seine drei tage ich weiß davon ja
ich hab mir vor wie kann aber ein ganzer
monat eine ganze reise ich habe so viel
erlebt ich hab das bei einem tag
zwischen an dem ich nichts hatte und
dann habe ich zuschauer auf die irene
aufmerksam gemacht die dort in new york
geht aus deutschland oder häufig
praktischen blind date mit ihr reden und
sie hat mit der new york gezeigt so
einmal im schnelldurchlauf
es war echt cool wir haben auch heute
noch kontakt und ich werde sie mit
sicherheit wieder besuchen
mittlerweile hat auch ein baby als ein
kümmert und baby kuscheln und es war
also york muss man wirklich mal erlebt
haben das ist wirklich wie bielefeld
viele fehler
also new york oder bielefeld aber weißt
du was mein highlight in new york war
was das war das central park und ich
habe mich einfach mit der rega
hingesetzt eine stunde saßen wir da im
central park und dem einfach nur
menschen beobachtet und zwar rechts zwar
echt mega cool richtig schön da würde
ich gern noch mal hinreißend gerne mit
dir ich nehme ich mit
okay was auch ganz cool war das einfach
wir hatten ja klitschko bei uns daheim
war ja krass oder ist ein helm klitschko
aber bei uns hat uns besucht einfach so
hat war bei uns im garten hat mit gummi
geschenkt na ja sagt uns kaliber ist der
papa geht zum vladimir klitschko und
sagt zu mir hey du wir können jetzt
kämpfen
und da sagt geplante man von oben nach
unten also richtig dass riesengroß ist
weg geschrieben und er sagte zum papa
nein ich würde gerne ich würde gern
nicht wie ihnen kämpfen ich habe zu viel
respekt vor ihnen sie haben schon
geworden sie haben schon gewonnen und
lassen sie es und da kommt das pendant
zu mir und sagt sie habe angst
krass oder ich muss echt sagen ich mag
den platinen vitali die breiten brüder
die sind einfach die haben den totalen
respekt vor jedem menschen also die sind
echt voll die vorbilder findig und auch
die art wie sie sind einfach respekt und
das oftmals menschen kennen wie so oft
wird öfters passiert ja frank elstner
kennt ihn ja den klauen bekannten wir
schon länger foto von den fantastischen
vier die fantastisch wie allgemein und
wenn du mit den menschen so immer
einfach in der kabine rede ist oder was
ist dann merkt das ist ganz ganz normale
menschen und ganz liebe und einfach ganz
normal die sind alle voll normal und ich
habe das nicht verstanden wenn wir
irgendwie auf signierstunden waren und
auf messen und dann sagen die die
zuschauer ihr seid ja so wie in dem
video sondern denke ich mir so hell wie
sollen wir denn sonst sein aber wenn ich
dann menschen kennengelernt habe die ich
vielleicht aus dem fernsehen kannte oder
aus dem film oder aus der öffentlichkeit
da dachte ich mir auch kraß die sind
irgendwie so völlig normal und alles
ganz normale menschen weil ich sagen
muss ich bin froh dass dem nicht so ist
wie im boxring sogar richtig gemacht
wäre hinfällig gemacht ich hätte
natürlich auch die wahrheit kam dass ich
momentan in form war zum glück habt ihr
euch nicht angelegt
was ich ja auch immer ganz gerne mache
sind die nachgemacht videos das heißt
ihr schlagt mehr produkte für oder ich
wohl einfach lebensmittel und macht sie
nach was man gemacht bis jetzt müssten
erst opel classic
der fing aus syke liga für mich schon
gemacht und letztes jahr war ein cooles
highlight war das rennen jerry's kopiert
die novelle ist ja wir haben probiert
wie die anderen haben was kopiert
jetzt kann ich habe diesmal kam was
schlimmes und sagen wir haben einen tag
nachdem er das video hochgeladen haben
haben wir die nachricht kamen nach einer
idee von managerin ben jerry's und ich
habe mir ernsthaft gedacht ok jetzt ist
es so weit ich hab es wunderbar dass du
kriegst eine abmahnung jetzt heißt hier
auf die sachen zu kopieren
ich mein ich ich mache die rezepte
einfach so nach so wie mir der geschmack
kommt also ich kenne keine geheimrezept
oder deswegen kann ja eigentlich keiner
was tun
ich hatte auch richtig angst bällen
cherix das ist nämlich die decke geht es
im endeffekt auch und was ist passiert
ein tag später bekommen eine nachricht
und ben jerry's und jetzt haltet euch
fest
ich habe gesagt okay jetzt mit anwalt
einschalten nein verschreiben die zurück
eingehen hatten nach vermont er wir
haben uns nach nach nach in die usa
eingeladen und bekommen wir zeigen dir
sogar wie wir das machen ein bisschen
unser werk oder ich darf wieder so okay
ich hatte es kopiert und senaten mich
einfach ein ja und schimmer folgt mit
euch jemand einfach nach amerika
einladen und sagen kommt da einfach uns
besuchen und unter ihr müsst antworten
leben hat er die zeit ohne spaß mich
echt schon wir haben die zeit nicht
gehabt dorthin zu gehen dass uns
anzuschauen
da mussten wir machen folgendes wer
kopieren einfach dies dann noch mal ein
eis und vielleicht lassen sie uns doch
ein können jetzt bitte noch mal einen
hardware will ich wirklich gerne
besuchen
wir haben einfach mal versuchen wir
kopieren
jaja das nicht kopieren wie die anderen
okay was halten highlights für mich war
aber nicht von orads ich mag dieses jahr
bei den backstreet boys fehlt auch nicht
wo sich den 88 geboren ich bin ein kind
der 90er ich bin aufgewachsen mit den
backstreet boys ich habe die poster
gesammelt ich hab' ich hatte riesen
ordner mit zeitungsartikeln und
prospekten und meine mutter ist eben
alles weggeschmissen aber ich stinksauer
aber ich war einfach ich bin back street
beckereit und ich war zuerst in mannheim
und es war also ich hatte erst karten
für berlin gekauft weil ich mich
wusste ob ich für die sap arena noch
welche krieg und dann im letzten moment
habe ich noch für die sap arena welche
krieg und ich war einfach zwei mal auf
einem konzert von den backstreet boys
vor dem wechsel posse vergebens
highlights highlight ja vor allem weil
ich mit meinen mädels dort war halo 2
unsere schulzeit es war meine jugend wo
ich hab bis alle glücklich verheiratet
haben alle kinder und es sind auch ganz
normale menschen und scheidet wie wir
alle auch arbeit war für mich einfach so
mein gott
beckereit furchtbar so weiter macht den
besonderen highlights 2008 hingegen sehr
größtenteils um den bau und 2019 da
haben wir schon hier im haus gewohnt
und dann ging's größtenteils um den
garten genau dass das was am haus am
meisten sportler im endeffekt muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen ist die daten
gestaltung
du siehst du machst es morgens und
abends sie schon das ergebnis und garten
ist sowas dankbares und ich lieb'
unseren garten reicht das schönste
unserem haus ist egal zu sein ist
einfach so viel schon zurückgegeben wir
haben dieses jahr die ganze frucht bäume
gepflanzt die sträucher christian war
bei uns frau aus marburg und lebensräume
morgen genau die nada zusammen haben wir
gar ecke stehen auch okay da jeder
kochen nummer dankeschön peter danke
christian das war so toll ich mit euch
garten etwas machen und ich denke auch
für die zuschauer die ganzen garten
videos nummer 1000 angriffe und wir
haben den garten dieses jahr angelegt
und er hat uns schon richtig viel
zurückgegeben ich habe die ganze
marmelade eingekocht das gemüse geerntet
als es war vegas läuse ameisen vögel die
uns auch auf die außenfassade geschissen
haben die kammern banken aber
überraschen lebe aber cool wirklich
liebt es einfach ok auf 1 hätte
verzichten können die kröten im garten
dass wir waren einfach mega laut ja wir
haben wirklich sachen im garten bestehen
und naturschutz
wer hauks kröten und gottesanbeterin wie
es hier eigentlich gar nicht ja auch
gott eigentlich noch an das bild waren
zudem gottesanbeterin wer muss auch
gemeldet übrigens auf dieser seite wo
man's melden uns genau
wir haben diese gemeldet und jetzt
gejagt und ungerecht weil ich freue mich
schon wieder dieses jahr auf den
frühling und auf den grafen und
bezüglich des gartens haben wir dann
auch gesagt weil viel lieber nach dem
gatten gefragt haben auch unsere freunde
und garten rundgang machen und dann
haben wir gemerkt ganz schnell okay wir
haben zu viele freunde und so viel
familie machen wir um gartenfest und aus
diesen familien freunden das gartenfest
wurde ein riesen einfach mal genau so
stiftungs aktionen wurde der aus die
stiftung hat dadurch natürlich einiges
zusammengekommen
die mauer war das gartenfest es war
wunderschönes raten fest und wir werden
dieses jahr wieder eins machen also wir
versprechen euch dieses jahr nochmal und
dieses jahr machen wir es nochmal cooler
wieder mit live musik und einem drum und
dran war wirklich wunderschön zwar recht
und alles im werden wir sehen uns wieder
in maur dieses jahr mit dem gartenfest
ja und dann nach der sommerpause ging es
eigentlich direkt wie jedes jahr nach
der sommerpause weiter mit der fifa und
die wir dieses jahr oder letzte auch
ganz besonders denn wir haben unsere
eigene app gelauncht
jahrelang wurden wir schon gefragt sally
macht doch mal ne app macht man aber so
eine app ist hat nicht so einfach
hergestellt die kann man nicht einfach
mal kurz programmieren da hat wirklich
monatelang jahre lage aber ist da
wirklich gedanken darüber gemacht was
machen wir
und auf der ifa haben das recht krachen
lassen muss ich sagen denn ich hätte
nicht erwartet wir haben echt gesagt so
ok kommen wenn 100.000 downloads
schaffen dadurch schon kräftige stärkung
müssen ende des jahres am nach drei
stunden ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz die
charts der bayern haben mir mcdonald's
weggeschossen
wir haben burger king weggeschossen wir
haben lieferando rick geschossen und
bisher nach drei stunden und ich habe
mir halt gedacht so ok kommen aber das
sind alles gut es geht um essen gehen
und einen tag später bezahlt meine augen
nicht glauben schau dir diese grafik es
war einfach ja waren die nummer eins in
den deutschen app charts wir haben
whatsapp weggeschossen facebook
weggeschossen haben google youtube
instagram als alle alles weggeschossen
war es lustig ist krank diesen
screenshot habe ich den robot kinzel dem
entwickler bei youtube geschickt und er
hat mir zurückgeschrieben
monatlich kommen nur weil ich versuche
euch wahnsinn und die app haben bis
jetzt über 52.000 menschen darum
gegangen die ist kostenlos kennen und
damit kannst du die ganzen buckle von
und alle geräte zuhause steuern eure
männer eure kinder alles sie halt alles
passen mit steuern und ihr könnt alles
ganz einfach die rezepte um rechnen das
heißt ich gebe die meisten rezepte ja
als vier personen haushalt anderer könnt
ihr so hoch oder runter rechnen ihr
können torten größer oder kleiner machen
ihr könnt den einkaufszettel schreiben
und direkt per web versenden da es gibt
wirklich ganz ganz viele tolle
funktionen und auch viele funktionen die
ich schon im kopf habe den ich auch
gerne noch machen würde
und die kommen dann alle noch dies ist
genau wie chemie oder aktualisieren wenn
wir uns jeden monat ein neues einfallen
lassen es werden demnächst auch portman
spiele kommen oder sowas ja aber
vorlegen und die app ist wirklich
kostenlos und ganz wichtig auch ohne
werbung ja was direkt nach der ifa ein
großes highlight war war der youtube
gold und der kamerad digital award genau
wir haben dieses jahr die goldene kamera
gewonnen und für mich ist die goldene
kamera wirklich schon eine krasse
auszeichnung weil das kennt jeder
das kennt jeder und schon ein
anerkannter preis ja das war schon dort
habe ich auch ich hab zwar schon länger
kontakt zu eben kein blaume getroffen
tja frank elster getroffen und disco
lieber bei dem event sitzt hinter mir
wirklich eigentlich schon erzählt die
fanta 4 die helden meiner meiner jugend
und auch jetzt noch meine helden und
dann klopft mir das motto auf die
schulter und sagt dann zu mir und ich
finde es so krass was ihr macht er hat
mein name ausgesprochen
und ich finde es so krass was ihr macht
und hat gesagt wir sollen mitmachen
damit sagt klar und wer seine jungen
leser waren session waren so was
geflasht und ich hab das allen meinen
freunden erzählt und das coole war dann
zwar smudo auch bei uns in waghäusel uns
besuchten am markt zeigt dass ich es so
machen genau also das motto bei youtube
chef sie waren alle hier in waghäusel
und dieses jahr eine krasse geschichte
für uns und unglaublich wie viele
menschen und lieber smudo
wir machen noch nie zusammen jetzt zwei
ja okay ich okay ist das kind hat jetzt
weiß motorrad darf es ruhig bis hörstel
assistiert zusammen
ich packe ich zitate genau und die band
empire kuratoren wie van zafira das ist
die fantastischen fünf mal wegen immer
er ist es hat alles gefehlt hat so ist
ich bin schwabe
aber weit gefehlt ich denke die
fantastischen fünf bin ja jetzt gerade
30 jahre tour
wir haben schon mit einsteigen können
wir mit einsteigen ich glaube es werden
maximal erfolgt wir haben ein döner
laden nach dem anderen voll machen
verspricht euch lasst uns was zusammen
machen und zu jeder tour gibt's dann die
fanta später 18 kommt man wahrscheinlich
lustig ist dass die fantastischen vier
mich müssten das die fanta schlechte
gibt er ich habe gesagt habe ich packen
der fanta sprite mit euch und den wird
es nicht verstanden weil sie nicht
wussten was nachbarn damit ist das bag
geburtstagskuchen schlechthin der
blechkuchen mein lieblingslied ein paar
mehr mein lieblingslied die dass dank
dieser ist und ehrlich ich finde
mfg natürlich er dann ein tag am meer
die damals 38 3 1 und kreisky und noch
ein sonderzug nach pankow
nee das war udo lindenberg foto helfe es
auch coole socke dieses jahr war der
murat auch relativ häufig alleine
unterwegs oder nicht morath allein in
new york sondern murat allein in der
türkei
ja das habe ich unsere hersteller
besucht genau ich habe die herrschenden
besucht und ich hatte mir hat keiner was
gemacht ich hab mich den präsidenten
beleidigt war alles in ordnung gewesen
hier spart übrigens erste mal die türkei
und bin papa ein paar war zusammen mit
präsidentin
wir haben tritt unterwegs
unterschiedlicher die typen geht es gar
nicht mehr los deutsch deutsch türkisch
und papa einfach türkisch
warum unterwegs und haben die brannten
besucht produktion besucht muss
ausgefüllt war eine geniale geschichte
wir haben das video mit den gusseisen
tippten kam jetzt ist ja schon jetzt
kommt die videos mit den teppichen und
mit den farben und formen war richtig
genial und ich liebe die türkei zu
zeigen weil mich interessieren die
politik noch die religion ich möchte die
menschen zeigen so wie sie wirklich sind
und ich versuche anderen menschen auch
mal als ich als zuschauer man anderen
blick nicht über die türkei zu geben
weil jenseits der ganzen medien und ich
glaube die leute sind begeistert gewesen
auch über die gastfreundschaft der
türkei richtig cool ich denke hat auch
ich meine wir kennen die türkei von
unseren eltern und für uns ist es halt
echt relativ einfach dann auf die türkei
zu zeigen und ich würde mir halt
wünschen
ich interessiere mich zum beispiel auch
mal für eine reise nach italien oder
nach griechen aber ich würde gern wissen
wo kann ich da hingehen weil sie so
insider tipps weil ich will ich in
irgendwelche hotels wo es einfach nur
all inclusive gibt und man nix von den
menschen und der kultur sieht und ich
glaube das hat die menschen bei dir so
begeistert durch einfach dein handy
genommen oder oder dem jörg schmidt
genommen und hat einfach die leute so
hautnah mitgenommen haben und zwar nur
schauen zusammen die türkische dreht
wieder gefunden und zwar wie sie denn
mich hier die türkischen veto die
funktion nämlich so wahnsinn
[Gelächter]
wir sind gar nicht so doof mein freund
ja ja und das kaliber der joschi
snowboarder und wir haben über schnee
geredet haben wir statt kommerz mit dem
ein schneegebiet dann haben wir im
schnee gebieten der türkei im ist ich
glaube spring spricht sich erst richtig
erscheint der ages der mann im schnee
gebiet der mauer plötzlich in
kappadokien noch nie gesehen also sind
ja sachen selber erlebt hat weiß dass
sie herrn portillo stets ein oft die
hose gemacht habe ich habe diese orte
selber noch nicht gesehen und war
einfach geflasht kappadokien absolut
geheimtipp in der türkei brutal sollte
toni gesehen hätte es zum schnee frost
und skifahren wirklich der wahnsinn hat
sich die wir mal ich würde mir wünschen
dass wir diese sehr gemeinsam so eine
kleine türkei tor machen
das würde mir nicht wünschen nicht die
medien schon mal
hallo dann gehe ich nach new york also
eine original war das pulver und die
türkei auf eine ganz andere art und
weise und weitere videos folgen doch mal
cool und vielen dank für euer feedback
und zudem kein spaß 21 millionen views
innerhalb einer woche auf instagram bei
mehr stimmt bei mir auch mal ist im
kanal dem über 21 millionen news und
wenn jetzt hat vom papa erzählt haben
okay das ist es zeigen
danke dass jetzt dass wir angegriffen
werden apropos eltern wenn man da schon
dabei sind oder apropos papa wir haben
ja auch die wohnung für meine eltern
gebaut haben es auch schon komplett
eingerichtet dekoriert und das war
wirklich nur noch der letzte schritt
dass sie in ihrer alten wohnung
zusammenpacken und hier oben einziehen
und dann ist einfach passiert und es kam
einfach viele neue menschen dazu bei uns
sarah samira der york die alin kam noch
dass zu holen wie wir noch nahezu b&s
das team ist einfach irgendwie von der
einen auf die andere woche so stark
gewachsen dass wir teilweise bei uns
drüben schon im büro im wohnzimmer im
esszimmer gearbeitet haben und ich habe
irgendwann zu morax hatte ganz einig
aber das bringt zunächst auch meine
eltern gesagt kommt dass das macht
keinen sinn einräumt unsere wohnung das
hat mir die wohnung ausgeräumt alle
möbel zwischengelagert und haben jetzt
oben erstmal alle büros eingerichtet
damit wir hier wirklich in ruhe arbeiten
können
aber es steht schon einplanen denn wir
haben mich hier leben dran im grundstück
wo wir praktisch jetzt schon angefangen
haben mit den bauarbeiten
das ist eben diese sally conway genau
ist das was sie gefragt habe die ganzen
was genau dort werden wir auch arbeiten
wir hätten neue arbeitsplätze schaffen
wir werden die projekte die wir immer so
im kopf haben und wir haben echt immer
viele projekte im kopf viele coole ideen
wollen wir dort einfach realisieren
da war der youtube chef sagt auch gerade
mehr heißen vor ein paar wochen robert
kissel war das ist ein gegner bei
youtube und ist aus los angeles hierher
geflogen hat sich sehr mit dem very
angeschaut und sie werden dabei sein
in waghäusel also eine ganz krasse
geschichte und zerlegen ist wirklich das
ist kein fake
das wird ein arbeitsplatz für kreative
menschen und für uns und was ist eine
gemacht das nicht ausschließt
bearbeitung was kreatives wissen was
sowieso ich werde bei uns verschmilzt
alles ja ja und das war es mir kommen so
wird zum beispiel ideen werde ich so
kurz vorm einschlafen bin ne
bundeskanzlerin war morales wachsen
genau wie man im bundeskanzleramt und im
europaparlament ja und ich mein ganzes
schiff nie gedacht dass ich jemals mit
der politik irgendwie in irgendeiner
weise zu tun haben werde ich auch nicht
deswegen beim bundeskanzleramt habe mich
so herein gelassen kein spanier mit
dorothea kennengelernt
unsere digital ministerin ja coole
geschichte dame richtig kommen sagte ja
das sagen der tafel frau und ganz
sympathisch und ich freue mich schon
darauf sie wird uns auch hier besucher
genau und sie finde es toll was wir aus
waghäusel heraus machen ja und das wird
wirklich versuchen die weltherrschaft an
uns zu reißen
war es nicht die stolzen braucht liebe
durchschnitt du bist wie plankton von
spongebob zum klang von java ist nicht
gerade als plankton bezeichnen ist ja
weil wir lachen hatten die renault eine
zelle hat und nur ein auge nur einen
augenblick centers und er als sondern
langsam und libero wir werfen wirklich
hier in waghäusel was geniales machen er
und wo wir über dem ganzen land darüber
spricht mit ihnen los insel sprechen sie
schon über seine kinder und ich bin
schon gespannt darauf wen wir dieses
jahr alles kennenlernen werden wer
dieses jahr zu uns zu besuch kommt und
ich meine wir hatten ja auch ein paar
coole youtube kooperationen der sturm
machte zb mit jenna jacob babbel war da
und ich denke ihr habt bestimmt auch
einige tolle vorschläge mit wem wir mal
gemeinsam videos machen können senioren
socken waren da und cool ist immer wenn
es etwas ist voll mit leuten die nicht
kochen und backen denn aber da ist für
euch auch interessanten den menschen
noch lustiger erlag am fitness
brokerwahl cool wenn er fit ist youtube
er war cool wenn du machst zusammen
machen würdest weil das ist damit hier
setzen damit hast du gar keine
berührungspunkte liegestützen oder soja
und fitness habe ich gar nicht ich bin
eher ich bin erst der fitness weniger
fitness mehr fitness ja ja das ist ein
neues logo der vorsatz fürs neue jahr
ja weniger fitnessketten ist hier so ist
okay aber ich glaub ich meine wir
könnten jetzt auch stunde lang über
unser letztes jahr erzählen mir schon
jetzt voraus jetzt neue jahr aber jetzt
klären wir noch eure fragen und deswegen
kommt jetzt die fragerunde
mein gott was ist eure fragen hatte ich
nicht mehr weg lashes nächste woche das
ist es ja was sollten dass das mich in
sachen unterstellt werden der eine sagt
ich war zu groß er hat gesagt so viele
menschen sagen dass ich werde immer
gefragt ob ich schwanger bin ich wünsche
mir unbedingt als ganzes aber nicht weil
ich habe schon drei kinder ich war ich
schon es gibt momentan eine erhöhung auf
2 105 euro pro kind lohnt sich das ist
doch jedes mal diese kindergeld so
witzel ja ok aber wenn du dir 8 wenn du
dir dann richtig coolen neuen witz
einfangen
dann kann man darüber das dritte kind
sprechen aber nicht wieder kinder gern
das klingt dritte kind im kindergarten
kostenlos ist wer von euch steuer den
größten unterschieden werden ich habe an
meiner hochzeit habe ich ballerinas
anziehen müssen ich doch keine high
heels anziehen weil er sagte ich darf
nicht das auf dauer unsere politik ist
ein kleiner bruder der sie ja im unfall
und seinen polterabend ich hatte so ein
richtig schönes petrol farbene kleid an
hast du auch gleich soll
sandaletten es da ganz ehrlich ich finde
das stimmt mich absolut nicht ehrlich
was zählte steht innere größe der mich
stolz als sonst hätte ich ihnen ja nicht
geheiratet so ist es nur acht zentimeter
warum sich das konnte man so aufwächst
so schwach sind würde lieber ein ruhiges
leben führen auch schon ich glaub ja
aber eher selten
ich glaube es wäre gelogen wenn wir
sagen würden ist immer alles friede
freude eierkuchen und alles immer
megatoll manchmal kommst du echt schon
an deine grenzen hat jetzt nicht nur
sondern ich meine jetzt uns weiter
also wir jetzt gut oder ich nicht mehr
weiter ich ein oftmals haben so viele
projekte parallel am laufen und wobei
wir selber schuld sind weil wir die
brücke abstützen und jedes jahr sage ich
mir okay die sache aber echt weniger und
dann kommen halt wieder so einfälle wie
auch stressig wird keinen kindergarten
bauen mal so
ich meine klar wird was ich manchmal
einfach von ruhigeres leben aber dann
denke ich mir wieder die ich brauche
einfach diese herausforderung ich bin
glaube ich kein mensch der jeden tag das
gleiche machen könnte und es ist krass
wie viele berichte oder richtigen wir
gehen aber ich kann euch heute ganz
genau erzählen was sind ein gutes
olivenöl ausmacht was keramik ist was
der isst was gusseisen truppe aus mag
das ein messer ein gutes messer ausmacht
wie gemüse angepflanzt oder ihre fische
gezüchtet werden ich habe gerade so viel
soll mehr denken am besten an der
außenfassade am lenker und sozusagen sie
habe früher nie gedanken gemacht
inzwischen weiß ich über alles irgendwie
bescheid und und ich finde es auch das
coole für uns weil es welt ich es ja
wirklich am anfangs handys torten wände
und irgendwann habe ich gemerkt so ganz
wird das passt gar nicht mehr weil ich
bin nicht nur torten und dass wir müssen
unsere welt erweitern und eigentlich
passt alles was momentan uns bewegt
immer auf unseren kanal und jetzt macht
immer spaß wenn man weißt du gar nicht
was was am ende der woche dabei
herausspringen ja kommen werden nicht
geplant dass wir mal im kindergarten
bauen wollen er hat noch seine ideen
bauten den kindergarten baut so
geschafft er ist unser haus zu behalten
ist schwierig aber vielleicht sagen das
war von anfang an unsere planung war
keinem keller zu bauen und verfolgen das
mein papa und mama mussten keller bauen
und house oder keller ist kein richtiges
haus und ich hab mir aber gedacht wir
hatten jetzt jahrelang immer im keller
in jeder wohnung wo wir gewohnt haben
die hat er immer im keller und der
keller stand immer voll und ich denke
mir halt immer so wenn du einen raum
hast den du nicht jeden tag betrittst
wie ein keller oder garage dann stellt
das automatisch wollen und ich wollte
einfach keinen raum schaffen der
vollstedt das heißt alles was hier im
haus ist sonst einen platz haben und
alles was keinen platz hat sich
anscheinend überflüssig und ist es schon
so hat der erste step thema machen muss
glaube ich muss sich von dingen trennen
genau und alles was du nicht innerhalb
von drei monaten gerne nicht einmal
benutzt brauchst du das brauchst außer
saison
die weihnachtsdeko oder winterklamotten
und saglik grill
typisch raclette holt die im jahr nur
einmal raus und es ist so weit
jetzt bekomme ich auch aber das ding ich
halt auch ich bin jemand der hat gern
ordnung und wir haben auch wirklich für
alles seinen platz und ich bin auch
gerade noch so bei den endzügen alles zu
beschriften weil ich denke wenn das
betrifft ist dann kann man nichts
anderes hinstellen wenn da steht shampoo
dann kann stand einfach deinen de oder
abstellen genau und an sonst haben wir
das zusammen also manchmal hilft mir
mega viel ich muss echt alles war wie
immer war so dankbar dafür dass meine
eltern gesund sind und dass meine eltern
hier vor ort sind und dass wir ihnen
viel geben können dass sie uns viel
zurückgeben können das ist wirklich gold
wert und bei uns im team
wir sind wie eine familie ist wirklich
so wie man sagt dass oft aber es ist
wirklich so
und bei uns gibt es jetzt keinen der
sagt ich bin kameramann und ich muss
meinen ja mein arbeitsplatz sauber jeder
verlässt man von unserer mehr dran
erinnern andere werden sich dagegen sein
wir machen alles zusammen saubere alle
menschen die hier arbeiten für
vornherein ist es sauber ist dann
brauchen wir so was gerade machen das
alles hier haben vor allem titel
vielleicht hat weniger zu tun haben die
gucken dann mehr drauf hast keine ahnung
bei volkan und sehr mag im büro oben da
räumt dann der wahl kam er auf einer
sagt dass er macht jetzt etwas anderes
nachricht ist oder der franck den müll
raus und das schon ein video von einer
situation wegen welches service und zwar
da ich erinnert alle menschen daran
die das jetzt sehen 19 96 das war ich
glaube es um 10 uhr 30 war die
hallenmeisterschaft der c jugend in
balingen und da habe ich das
entscheidende tor geschossen 19 96 10 30
und von dieser situation hätte ich gerne
ein video gehabt ich weiß nicht mit
letzter kraft gekämpft haben uns den
schneid abkaufen
war das jetzt blöd ich jetzt sagen
sollen die geburt meiner kinder
ich wollte kurz sagen die geburt meiner
kinder hat dann habe ich mir überlegt
nein nein ich fahre ganz dramatisch also
warst du mal die auf 996 gewinn der
hallenmeisterschaft in der cdu bisher
vergeben die mlb die poker als er diesen
diesen touchdown gebracht hat und es war
wirklich 296 ich sah was wirklich mal
cooler wenn man wirklich sowieso eine
zeitreise machen könnt ich habe halt
keine videos aus meiner kindheit und
wenn man irgendwie sowas nochmal in die
vergangenheit zurück reißen könnte und
schauen könnte wie war ich eigentlich so
als kind mein papa da erzählt mir schon
immer wie brav und ruhig war
du wolltest doch wieder zurück und das
werden aber was ist los geworden
ja also ich habe bis 2014 meiner
referendariat gemacht und in diesem jahr
wohl auch anfangen zu arbeiten aber an
der grundschule mit herz gab verkenne
stelle deswegen wollte ich einfach ein
halbes jahr warten
in einem halben jahr da ist die silke in
schwangerschafts urlaub ich gehe dann
wieder zur schule zurück aber ich habe
mich dann irgendwie auf youtube
konzentriert und vielleicht gehen wieder
zurück ich gehe wieder zurück da
überlegte einen tag die woche zwei tage
die woche zur teilzeit in der schule
arbeiten aber es hat einfach zeitlich
nicht funktioniert und ich habe als auch
zum morax ich bin jetzt zu 100 prozent
mit meinen gedanken und mit meinem
vollen körpereinsatz hier bei uns sind
es welt und ich kann da nicht parallel
was anderes machen weil wenn ich jetzt
in der schule arbeitet will ich dort
auch 100 prozent geben um es geht nicht
und ich habe jetzt einfach für mich
beschlossen ok momentan übe ich einfach
keine lehrertätigkeit aus aber ich werde
zum bildungsauftrag fort denn ich bringe
menschen etwas bei nicht einer
schulklasse dafür aber euch allen und
einen mann in volkenschwand soll ich
gesagt grundschule mit herz hätte ich
sowieso war bei mir hieß es immer die
baustelle ist oder nicht wenn ich mir
auf dem bau gearbeitet habe und was soll
ich sagen
bei uns ist die baustelle des todes
regieren wenn mir steine geklopft haben
bei uns damals
der kalksandsteinwerke das war meine
arbeitsstelle ganz sicher seid dass er
wenn er viel geld hat wir haben uns
kennengelernt vor zwölf jahren
und dann haben wir uns immer getroffen
habe ich meine eltern es fix davon aber
ich war schon 18 kommt das dauert darf
so erlaubt sein ich meinen immer mit 30
grad kommen und sagen ich habe hier
meinen ersten freund wird okay wir uns
kennengelernt und nach drei wochen sagte
murat sln ich an gleich mal deine eltern
kennen und ich habe erst gedacht
ein schuldiger meine eltern die wissen
dass ich freund heiraten doch sowieso
und das war praktisch mein heiratsantrag
und ich habe einfach gesagt ja ok und es
war halt in dem moment ich kann es nicht
mehr beschreiben also wenn mir das jetzt
jemand erzählen würde würde ich sagen
das spiel studio kann doch nicht einfach
jemanden heiraten
seit drei wochen kämpft aber es war
finde ich ich hatte irgendwie einfach
dieses gefühl dass der monat der
richtige ist und ich war doch dabei gibt
es kein rezept das macht mir einfach so
vertraut und ich weiß nicht warum hast
du mir das gesagt warum hast du zu mir
gesagt nach drei wochen schon wann lerne
ich dann eltern kenne ich meine steht
drauf was dabei gedacht haben da ist das
ding doch erinnern kannst hast du mir
damals was gebacken und ich wusste das
hat so genial geschmeckt hat gedacht ich
hab's gekauft ja die dominosteine
gebacken und ganz viele plätze ja nicht
nur ich muss jetzt einfach glauben ich
habe weil sie zwar auch mit sicherheit
glück ich glaube da gibt es kein ich
glaube es war es dieses gefühl oder das
hat man oder man hat es nicht und ich
glaube wenn ich habe das oft schon im
freundeskreis erlebt die dann auch
jemand kennengelernt haben und dann
haben sie sich irgendwie verpflichtet
gefühlt jemanden zu heiraten und dann
nach sechs monaten gemerkt okay da war
es nicht aber ich glaube wenn du am
anfang schon zweifel hast dann muss man
es vielleicht wirklich noch mal
überdenken und sagen okay dann
überstürzt halt nix aber wenn du
irgendwie von anfang an dieses gefühl
hat standen dann machst einfach ich
meine du kannst nach zehn jahren sagen
wir heiraten uns geht schief da gibt es
kein geheimrezept und auch sich nicht
zwingen zu lassen zu sagen jetzt haben
alle gaal ja muss es jetzt auf alle
jetzt zweites kind haben alles aus uns
macht euch selber druck macht das was
euch gefällt und heiraten menschen der
euch wirklich gut und respektiert und
das ist das wichtigste dass jemand
findet der die arbeit respektiert und
die du in unterstützen kannst also ich
unterstütze meine frau und sie
unterstützt auch nicht gern und wir sind
freilich vom charakter her
grundverschieden ja absolut
also ich glaube unterschiedlicher geht
schon fast gar nicht genau ich habe sie
zum beispiel noch nie mit schlechter
laune erlebt morgens wirklich noch nie
und ich bin genau das gegenteil oder
also unser geheimnis ich sag's euch
jetzt ich spreche ihnen einfach vor zehn
und ich ja so ist es wir sollten
vielleicht generell unsere
teambesprechung auf 11 uhr lernen oder
wie sterne
ob er dann ab morgen sind da gibt es
keine geheimnisse geben können wir haben
richtig doch nicht genannt das war das
geheimnis um das gebiet ist vertrauen
und dass man den anderen unterstützt und
dass man sich nicht von anderen regeln
und von anderen menschen unter druck
setzen weil jetzt auch jetzt kein
company
meine mutter hat immer gesagt eine frau
wenn du ne frau schießt dann musst du
sie in der küche beobachten wenn sie
richtig in der küche arbeiten dann ist
die richtige frau und er haben war es
gibt frauen die nicht kochen und backen
können sind von guter ehefrauen und
partner also dann ist sicherlich favorit
aber da muss man nach kochen und backen
kannst du so einfach gut aussehen ja ich
sehe schon die kommentare bamm bamm bamm
bamm bamm
wieso hat er das gesagt alice schwarzer
kommentiert das fragt wenn der hütte
auch jeden tag bekomme ich nehme ich
jetzt in schutz okay das problem ist vor
wirst mich sieht man in der küche
arbeiten am laptop arbeiten am pc
arbeiten mit den kindern im haushalt und
bei murat ist einfach so es sieht aus
als wäre der den ganzen tag am handy
herum dortelweiler einfach das handy
nutzt um seine texte zu schreiben für
den katalog fürs buch für online für
postings er kommentiert extrem viele
kommentare also viel mehr sinn ist ohne
spaß tun wirklich leute wir stehen nicht
jedem recht viel danach zu 23 45 und das
ding ist einfach whatsapp ist dein büro
whatsapp ist man ich habe mir extra nen
büro
dazu werden gäste haben extra für ihn im
büro gebaut gemeinsam und er nutzt halt
nicht weil er es lieber am handy
und dann sitzt da halt auf dem sofa und
es sieht aus als wäre so kurz vorm
jährliche video auf youtube was an mama
fragt immer warum arbeitet denn egal ob
ich mache so viel im garten ich bring
den müll raus ich wohl eher in der abt
bringt wieder weg das ist keine arbeit
ist ein papa dann bringst weg da muss es
auch wieder abholen diesen sachen hat
und gucken haben uns aber eines kann ich
euch sagen jetzt wirklich aus vollem
ernst wir arbeiten beide sehr viel und
auch gerne gerne und er arbeitet auch
genauso viel vielleicht nicht genug für
mich weil ich hab da noch mehr haushalt
als er aber ich wollte ich sagen der
arbeit genauso viel wie ich mache schon
ein bisschen mehr komme ich habe auch
immer die verantwortung einzige wunde
stelle war nie meine augen zu ich denke
ich denke sogar beim schlafen sommer
haben wir keine feuerwehr die die dinger
diese fragen von bränden kommt wir
werden dies nicht mittragen
wem interessiert ist wie groß meine füße
ja ich glaube einfach weil wir wissen
wir haben einen großen unterschied und
dann würden daher gern wissen ob deine
füße auch kleiner sein als die männer
das hat nichts damit zu tun folgendes
ich habe schon ganz direkt eine fuß ich
habe ihn noch in richtung also ich habe
schuhgröße 42
ich habe 41 das ist erst das nächste ist
umso älter du wirst umso größer werden
seine füße ist so die füße die nase die
ohren und die finger die sony
aufzuwachsen echtzeit man seine fans ist
das ist wieso sind diese was werden sie
mit einem kleinen kind ihn da rein
ich habe kleine hin aber das kleine feld
da was braucht ein guter handwerker auch
für die mechanik
deswegen sind meine hände sind auch
jemand bodenverbände fuß fragen und
diese füße fragen dementierte fohlen
fans schämen sich und jahren für die
füße anderer menschen mit bunten ich
hasse füße also das liebliche gesänge
und auch nur sachen erfunden dass man
füße nicht sehen muss ja
oder dünsten sind momente fuß ständig
ich mache filme wie sony wie soll ich
sagen so eine abwehrreaktion wenn ich
merke sie können in einer misslichen
situation lasse ich mein fahren das ist
etwa herr kroos laufen und dann kamen
gestern erst nicht gibt's nicht mehr
prozent verfolgten fahren lassen
das haben wir dann realisierte ganzen
schule spaß auf dem sofa einzuschlafen
du merkst sich das gestern im wohnzimmer
retten und am lachen alle macht sie auch
noch einmal das thema ich versuche ein
versucht versucht obwohl sich die center
wir haben aber auch noch nie werde ich
wenn mir auch die zeit gar nicht dazu
haben um die möglichkeit nicht dazu
wenn ich mein ich weiß kommt schon viele
nachrichten an mich wo sie eifersüchtig
werden könnte dann schreibt sie aber
auch oftmals unternehmen doch einfach
wird denn murat auf der auf der stelle
heiraten ein bisschen dem hinter einfach
mit ja mich macht das ding wird das
selbst brennt ich hasse ist irgendwann
bringt murat jeder benutzt und kam ich
bin schon eine coole frau ist es möglich
hat sie oder ich bin nicht nachtragend
nein ich bin ich konnte kompliziert
allein bei diesem wort hatte probleme
sich auf jeden fall nein es ist wirklich
keine einfache aber ich vertrauen uns
halt so ist wenn was heute machen so
einer anderen rennen
wieso unter man weiß niemals die hand
zur mein gott was sind das für fragen
woher kommen diese fragen aus welchem
loch
ich frage ich natürlich wären beide ich
glaube bei uns gibt es nicht nur wer hat
die wollte dass meine mutter zu der
mutter versteht kein wort deutsch dann
biete sagt um israel zurück
ich trage jetzt ruhe denn worauf
dankeschön oder schwiegermonster später
mutter schwiegermutter ich muss echt
sagen am anfang fand ich ihre art
bisschen komisch weil meine eltern halt
anders eingestellt sind
aber ich habe einfach gemerkt okay die
kommen aus einer anderen region in der
türkei und sie hat halt andere werte
auch vermittelt bekommen von ihrer
familie sicher ganz anders aufgewachsen
und ich möchte da ist 74 jahre alt
die mega stolz auf ihre kinder und halt
auch vor allem auf ihre söhne und habt
ihr das geschafft ins gratis ist dieses
diesen o ton gehört dies vor allem stolz
auf ihre söhne meine mama ist wenn ich
eine person wies und fixiert und meint
es darf man auch sagen bisher dies hat
in einer anderen gesellschaft in anderen
formationen in einer anderen kultur
aufgewachsen und wenn ein mensch und ich
finde das gilt jetzt allgemein nicht nur
für deine mutter sondern für alle
menschen wenn ein mensch es nicht anders
kennt und einfach gewohnt ist so zu
leben dann finde ich darf steht noch
nicht verurteilen nur weil eine andere
ansicht hat ich meine klar gibt es noch
menschen die offen sind und sagen okay
es gibt auch andere welten aber mein
gott sie hat jahrelang so gelebt und
erlebt und wenn sie halt kommt und sehe
kommt jetzt nicht ganz oft weil sie lebt
in der türkei und will dort auch in
ihrem dorf leben wenn sie kommt dann
spiele ich halt die brave hausfrau ich
mein ich bin ein gutes schwiegertochter
macht er halt mit und dann ist sie
glücklich und wenn sie glücklich so
kannst du auf eine einigung so zu reden
dass meine mutter aus dem spiel dass ich
deine aus dem keller sieht dieses buch
einfach jede minute ist auch ganz treu
ich ganz ehrlich sagen ist eine
wundervolle frau und ich sage ja auch
mama zu ihr und papa schwiegerpapa und
mama was dann wirklich ganz wundervolle
menschen und ich glaube man kann sich
keine besseren schwiegereltern muss man
ganz ehrlich sagen ich muss echt sagen
ich hab's auch deiner mama schon oft
angeboten
mir wird es echt nichts ausmachen wenn
sie auch hier wohnen wird bei uns weil
ich finde die süße frau bringt irgendwie
alle zum lachen wie vor mit dem was uns
da draußen haben wir im gartenhäuschen
noch platz wie man spaß ist meine mama
ist auch ganz toll ist richtig lustig
ist echt lustig
ist ja mal schauen wo sie lustig finde
ist wenn sie mich immer fertig war ja
meine mama das ist auch gut so sagen
meinte ich verstehe ich gar nicht weil
sie so einen kasten dialekt spricht
das ist der hammer liegen mich auch an
dass ihr kennt ist aber normal
heimkindern du gehst du deinem kind hin
und sagt oh mein schatz gegen 17 kurs so
stolz auf dich ja und das erste was
meine mama sagt das war jetzt gar nicht
alles sagen dass er zu krass wie
beleidigt mich zuerst einmal kenne ich
kenne ja keine toilette gesagt dass du
mir zu toilette weiters dahinter stelle
die dar und steine auf die welt gebracht
lauda solche sachen das hört sich krass
aber das ist meine mama meinen dass ich
es halt mama setzen dann ohrfeigen so
hallo machen
das ist manchmal aber ist sie
aufgewachsen bin ich nur sagen wenn ich
möchte auch in den wortschatz ist dann
sagt 710 jetzt nimm dein weiter und komm
halt mal in die türkei aber die
meisterschaft ist und am anfang war das
halt voll verwirrend für mich weil ich
dann so denkt okay man optimistisch
schaut sie den katalog und auf dem
katalog gibt es diese dieses die seite
wo ich auf dem teppich drauf da guckt
sie dieses bild an und sagt warum haben
sie den affen aus dem gemacht was einige
fragen ja weil die machen wir schon
fertig mal die fragen die füßen immer
irgendwas mit höchstens unrecht weiß da
ist irgendjemand anderer befremdlich
also irgendwie befremdlich ich kümmere
mich nicht um die füße von anderen
menschen und das wieder mit dieses tat
transplantation der entschuldigung ich
werde jeden tag um mein untermain wie
das kompakte schwanger bin ich finde das
thema habe ich nur vielleicht viel
gegessen
ja auf jeden fall ganz coole fragen zum
teil ja einmal kohle rückblick er hat
und cooles jahr die sich ja das ist ja
jetzt 2020 genau ich freue mich drauf
ja also falls ihr noch fragen habt
anregungen wünsche für den kanal was
wollt ihr sehen dieses jahr schreibt
gerne die kommentare ich weiß schon was
kommt dass es nicht so kommt es wieder
macht's gut macht's besser macht's gut
macht's besser ein schönes neues jahr
euch allen und tschüss
ich rufe meine mutter jawohl ich ja erst
mal schön beleidigen
[Musik]